party everybody welcome to the wook
today's webinar we're gonna go ahead and
get started my name is Mike cope I'm a
product specialist at her go I'm gonna
kind of be moderating the chat section
today for Jason if you have any
questions go ahead and type those in the
chat area as we go we're going to have
two sections Jason's going to cover two
different things in this webinar number
one he's going to do the helix
programming and lines and arcs and we'll
pause for a brief question and answer
section then and then we'll go on to the
thread milling block and we'll have more
questions at the end of that so as the
webinar goes if you want i'm just go
ahead and type those questions in what
i'm going to do is i'll read each
question to jason so everyone will be
able to hear it and then let him answer
that way he can focus on just doing the
webinar so at this time I'll go ahead
and introduce team Jason Falk is a
applications engineer he's a senior
applications engineer with her Co he's
been with the company since 2004 and he
knows the control very very well so
probably any questions that you have
relating to this or other you could
probably help you with so at this time
I'll go ahead and turn it over to Jason
and and let him get started
all right hello everyone I am Jason fall
and we'll go ahead and get going here
the first thing that all kind of
mentioned is we are going to go over
programming using a helix and thread
mill today and the reason we've kind of
lumped those two features together is
they both kind of require the same
machine motion to get the geometry you
request it's both kind of a a three axis
x y&z constant motion a nice ramping
motion so we figured it was well kind of
talk about both those together since
they have that that common area a lot of
what I'm going to do today I'm going to
actually show you show you right along
how to do it in our wind max desktop
software for those of you that are not
familiar with it I'll go ahead and bring
it up on the screen here this is our our
win max desktop software this is the
exact same software that you would use
on the machine it just gives us the
ability to use it at our desktop PC we
could create programs here we could
verify programs we can even save those
programs off take them out to machine
and run them there so this is the exact
same thing you'll you'll see on the
machine and we may utilize a couple
features here which will even further
show that but I would like to mention
that if any of you would like a trial
version of the wind max desktop software
let us know there'll be some contact
information at the end of this
presentation you know and we can get you
a seat of this you know if you're at
home and you'd like to practice on what
we're going over we have some online
training videos that you can work along
with but if you would if you'd like to
try to use this a little bit definitely
let us know and we can we can hook you
up with with some software so we'll go
ahead and get right into helix before we
even get into the prints that we're
going to work with there's one thing I'd
like to clear up right away when you use
the term helix when talking with her co
programmers there's a couple different
things we could be talking about
and I want to make sure we're all on the
same page and the one that most people
are probably a little bit more familiar
with if we go into our program
parameters and then go into our milling
- tab on any conversational program
you'll notice that we have this plunge
type that we can set either as a
straight plunge or a helix plunge this
is just this just feels with plunging so
how do you want to enter your your
pocket if you had some geometry that you
wanted to pocket out maybe you have a
center cutting endmill and you can't
straight plunge that tool into the work
this gives you the ability to do that
it's going to give you a a ramping
motion similar to what we're going to
work with today however this is not what
we're going to deal with this just deals
with plunging what we want to work with
today is actually using a helix to
create geometry you know finished to
size geometry so what well this is very
useful for plunging this is not really
where we're going to spend our time
today and want to make sure I tried to
clear that up before we got into it I
have seen many customers in the past try
to use this helix plunge to create
finished geometry and well you can
probably do that there's a much easier
way to get that done
where all the numbers make sense so
that's where we're going to spend our
time with today to do this I'm going to
start with this simple print here you
can see that we've got you know a
contour around the outside that'll need
to be dealt with and we've got three
holes in the center of this part if we
take a look at each of these holes
you'll notice that each one has slightly
different diameters the one over here to
the right is a half-inch diameter hole
we have a point seven four five diameter
hole in the middle and a point seven
five five diameter hole over here on the
left side well if you look at the tool
list and I'm assuming that these are the
only tools we have available for us or
it's used today you'll notice that we
have a half-inch drill which we'll go
ahead and take care of this right-hand
hole that
sighs but we still need to open up these
other two holes now I can do this with
just a simple mil circle where I'm going
to plunge into my material do the mill
circle punch again and do another circle
but we're gonna do it slightly different
we're going to use the helix today and
kind of helix bore that or do a helical
and tribulation all the way through that
that circular shape to do this it will
be in lines and arcs and if I go ahead
and bring my wind Maxx desktop software
back on my graphics screen let me switch
programs deal with this one a little bit
later let's go into the thread program
and I'll go ahead and verify that I'm
sorry let's go into the helix program
I'll verify that one
if you take a look at the part I've got
most of it completed you know we've got
the con 4 created we're not gonna go
over that and we've got the three holes
drilled I went ahead and drilled these
other two holes Wow
that was not necessary but usually I
have a drill out I will go ahead and and
drill the center of a hole that I am
going to helix forth so we're just going
to go over how to open up these two
holes so we'll bring our print back so
you can kind of see where I'm getting my
information so if I go to the review
screen you know here's the holes block
that we've already created I'm just
going to go to that go to my next block
and to get to helix you're going to go
into your milling data blocks and then
just lines and arcs to start with we're
going to treat this like any other
contour when you start out through the
program so the first thing it's going to
ask for is an XY start point just like
any other contour you're going to find a
point that lies on this contour in this
case it's just that circular shape but
we're just going to try to come up with
a point where we know the dimensions I
think I'm just going to use this point
out here to the right I know it is a
point seven four or five diameter so if
I were to divide that by two so we'll
just take in the point seven four five
divided by two that'll give me the point
three seven two five for my X start
point you will notice the red cross or
in the center represents my part zero so
everything is based off X Y zero so my Y
start point will just simply be zero so
nothing outside of the normal from any
contour that we've worked with yet my Z
start the same as always as well you
want to make sure you're a little bit
above your part and this is where things
are going to start to vary a little bit
from the standard contour if we think
about what we're going to do here I want
to start above my part and then I want
to use a helical motion a helical
interpolation to take this circle to
size so since I want to start
above and work my way down I need to
make sure that my Z bottom stays above
my part at least in this segment zero
the mistake that most people make
because we're so used to doing it is
putting the the overall Z bottom in this
field if I were to put that in as the
overall Z bottom the negative 400
thousands or whatever it happens to be
on this front the machine would then
plunge to that point and then try to
helix this out however we're already
sitting at the bottom of that hole so
first thing make sure your Z bottom
remains above your material that's the
first hang-up people usually see and
while we're here I'm just going to go
ahead and put in what tool I want to use
I am going to do a left cutter comp so
that I can climb cut around the inside
of this going that direction and my
blend moves I'm going to turn those off
just for now so that we can see the tool
pass a little bit better for the helix
oh you can see what's going on so all
I've done so far is I've started out
here on this right quadrant point of
this contour and now I'm going to go
ahead and program the rest to do that we
just simply go to our next segment just
like any other contour rather than going
into the line or arc that many of you
are used to going into I'm going to go
down a couple more steps here and you
see the helix option this is what we're
going to use to create this geometry so
I'm going to select helix and just like
any other contour we're going to look at
each field and kind of see if we know
that information and give it the
information that we do know so the
direction and once node we want to go
clockwise or counterclockwise
I want to go counterclockwise here so
that I'm Clym cutting around the inside
of this circle so I will set that now
the next two fields the X and in the Y
end the biggest tip trick hint or
anything I can give you here to help
with programming a helix is do not click
anything in your X or Y end point you
know for those of you that are familiar
with contours there's a very powerful
math assist here and we're going to let
control do what the control does here so
that we don't have to try to make sure
that everything in is just exactly at
the right point so just leave these two
fields exactly blank and we'll come back
and hit on that again here towards the
end and we're going to give it the
information that we are concerned with
you know I really don't care where it
ends and x and y as long as it's
somewhere on that circle my Z and I'm
gonna go ahead and take that down to 400
thousands - 400 thousands so I'm going
through this part my center point of
this arc is the same thing as the center
point I'm sorry the center point of this
helix is the same as a center point of
an arc so I'll give it that information
which is just simply x0 y0 and you'll
see it calculated the radius so nothing
too much different other than from what
we're used to in standard lines and arcs
now we've got a couple of new fields
here that you may not be completely
familiar with the first one here being
lead and the description down here tells
us to enter the z axis lead value this
is how much we want this tool to raise
or lower for every revolution so for
every 360 degrees we travel around how
much should I have changed in Z to give
us that that ramping motion well we are
starting above the part and we are going
towards the bottom so this is going to
be a negative lead direction it is very
picky on that if you are going down into
the part it will be negative if you're
going up it will be positive so
typically you're going to have a
negative lead value and I'm going to say
I want to go
- 35,000 so for every revolution around
I should have dropped 35 thousandths
into the material you'll notice this
calculated the sweep angle area what
this is telling us is how many degrees
the machine has to make in order to get
to my - 400 thousands if I were to open
up the calculator and take that what is
it 40 320 and
by three-sixty this is telling me I'm
going to make 12 revolutions to get to
that that four hundred thousands you'll
also notice that it calculated my X&Y
end point which is exactly what we
wanted to do before we go much further
I'm going to go ahead and jump over to
the graphics screen and we will draw
this and to show you what we've got
going on so far if i zoom in on here
maybe rotate around you can kind of see
that we've got a ramping motion if I go
into a side view and zoom in you can
kind of see that we are a ramping into
this part one thing I would like to
point out if we look at the bottom of
this whole so we've got something going
on right over here
what this is is we told this to helix
itself down to that - 400 thousands and
then we ended that contour so the
control did exactly what we told it to
do it got to the end as soon as it got
there just lift it out of the hole so
what we're seeing here is where this
tool has not made a complete revolution
around at that bottom z-depth because we
have not yet told it to do so if you're
doing a through-hole that's not that big
of a deal usually I'll just make sure
that I my Z bottom is far enough below
my material that I can make at least one
revolution around with whatever my lead
is but if this is a bottoming hole we
need a nice flat surface we're probably
going to want to program an additional
segment into this contour so we'll go do
that so I'm on segment one I'm just
going to go to next segment just like we
we would in any other contour and I like
to do a helix here as well some guys
will use art and that's that's fine
whatever you like to use I'm just going
to use another helix one thing I will
caution you on is make sure your
direction is the same as it was before I
will come back and switch this here and
say I can show you what happens if it's
not but it can get get pretty ugly
pretty quickly so make sure your
direction is still going like
counterclockwise we want to make sure
our z end does not change my center
point should not have changed and my
lead now basically what I want to do is
force the control to rotate around this
part at least one more time to clean up
that bottom so I don't want Z to change
so I'm going to put zero in for my lead
and then my sweep angle I'm at least
gonna put 360 degrees in I actually
wanted to go around a couple different
times so I think what I'm going to do
will put seven hundred and twenty
degrees in there should force it around
twice to give us a nice flat surface and
kind of act as a spring pass as well so
we'll go ahead and we will draw this and
now you can see that we have a nice flat
surface there on the bottom I told you I
come back and show you what happens if
you forget to set your direction here
say I forget leave this at clockwise
which is a something that I do pretty
frequently when programming a helix I
get so wrapped up in these numbers that
I kind of forget to check this and I'll
leave it at that
luckily we have the verification
graphics when you go to draw this it
should be pretty pretty obvious right
away that something is wrong we are now
getting a much larger hole than what we
expected basically that is you know we
helix down one way with a left cutter
comp and then we got to that bottom of
that hole
and when we told it to now go the
opposite direction still with the left
cutter comp to go around so if you ever
see that make sure you change it before
trying to run your part I can tell you
from experience that it does not go well
if you forget that step so we'll draw it
to make sure everything looks good so
we're
to a a good helix toll that take this
one step step further so you can kind of
see what the machine is is doing I have
my desktop software set up as what we
call desktop complete which is basically
means I can load in a machine
configuration and then I can simulate
just as though I'm on a machine so I can
actually go into my auto mode assuming I
have no errors or anything in the
program let me check that so there are
no errors in the program I can actually
go through and run this so I'm just
going to tell it to run that block
number three run the program I'll kind
of slow it down here but what I was
wanting to see is my XY coordinates here
so you can see that we are helix into
the whole let's speed it up just a
little bit so down once we get to the
bottom now with that four hundred
thousandth and we're holding that 400
thousands as we make that seven hundred
and twenty degrees or those couple
revolutions one question I seem to get a
lot is once you add that second helix
will the machine try to pick up and then
come back down and you can see here that
it will not it's just one fluid motion
that helix is down to the bottom of that
hole it just then holds that constant
seed that rotates around a couple times
and then picks up out of the hole
so that there is the helix of the one
hole I will now go ahead and duplicate
that process for this other hole here
and I'm gonna cheat a little bit use a
little trick that I like to use when
working with helix I'm gonna program
this next helix as though it's sitting
right on part zero go back to my print
so I'm gonna program this helix as
though it's set here and I'm just gonna
use a pattern after I'm done to transfer
it over just to help keep my numbers
easy to follow on the screen so I'm
gonna go to my next block I'm going to
go into milling lines and arcs just like
before and again for the time being I'm
just going to assume my part zero is off
here to the left so we have a 755,000
diameter hole so if I do Oh point seven
five five divided by two we have a point
three seven seven five radius and I'll
start right on Y zero as well making
sure I leave my z bottom above my
material
all right so we should be all good to go
I'm just going to go into my next
segment again I'm going to go into helix
through a counterclockwise direction and
at the minus 400 thousands still using
the XY center point is 0 0 I'll use the
same - 35 foul play and program another
helix going counterclockwise same 400
sure I leave my lead at 0 on this second
segment and I'll go 720 degrees so now
if I draw this I should have two helixes
on the exact same point only one of
which is this correct so now I'll just
go in usually to my review screen
I will insert a block before the second
P licks go into patterns pattern
locations and I'm just going to shift
this over to where it should be on the
on the park if I pull the print back up
that should be X minus 3y minus 1.25 and
Z will be at zero they're on the same Z
depth for those of you that are familiar
with patterns once you start a pattern
you have to end the pattern so we'll go
do that I look at my review screen you
can see I have started the pattern I cut
the block and then ended the pattern so
now when I draw this we now have two
holes taken out the by diet are taken
out to diameter using the the helix
method so that there is how you would
use a helix and lines and arcs to create
a helical interpolation or to actually
create geometry using the helix
go ahead Mike are you down with this
section we have a well yeah the only
thing I was going to show is that in the
contour we do have the two helixes just
like if these were lines and arcs so
really nothing more than what you're
used to just maybe a slightly different
segment so go ahead Mike that's that's
all I've got there okay Dean is asking
the question how would you do this using
the DXF file transfer okay with with the
DXF there is no I guess hand way of
using it you could use it as telling it
to create a contour just to get your
points but really all you need when
you're starting your helix it's just
kind of this start point you know the
your X&Y end point and then you're going
to fill in the rest which could not be
taken from a DXF so you you could use
the D except to get that quadrant point
if you weren't quite sure of the
dimensions and then probably what I
would do is you know just have it create
that data block it should create an art
I would just delete all the other
segments and after I have the numbers
and insert a helix oh not a real you
know there is not a helix section in DXF
so I would kind of just use DXF to get
the information and then program it
manually okay one of the things can you
explain why you used the pattern
locations rather than just programming
the helix location yeah and to be honest
most of that is just my personal
preference my habit and I kind of
questioned whether I should do that or
not but it did add a little bit to the
presentation I think for those that may
not be familiar with it but the reason I
primarily do it you know everything's
nice and easy on this print as far as my
dimensions you know they're all nice
round numbers and when I went to go put
in that quadrant point for this segment
over there it was a pretty easy
calculation a lot of times that's not
the case you know if I wanted to start
on one of these two sides
have to take this - three-inch value and
they then either add or subtract the
radius so basically I was just
eliminating that step program to offer
zero then I can just easily put my
radius value in X and zero and Y which
is pretty common for how I do it
it just helps keep the number numbers
easier for me so it's by no means is it
necessary it's just a little I guess a
little thing that I like to do to help
keep things easier on my end okay and
the last question we have on this
section so far is can a lead out be used
yes I did turn those off so we could
kind of see the tool path a little bit
better but let's say I go into we'll
just do the block three here actually
let's just use this one down here the
the one all the way to the left if I go
in there enable my blend moves it is now
going to look in your program parameters
for your blend offset and blend overlap
to figure out how to blend off of this
but when I go to draw it oops
well the first thing I
take care of one issue it's there's no
space for blending now moves this is
just telling me with the tool that I
have selected there's no way for it to
offset whatever my value is without
hitting the back side of that hole or
helix in this case so I have a couple
options I can use a smaller tool or I
can just come into my blend offset and
overlap and back those down a little bit
without looking at the numbers and doing
the math here I think this whole take
care of that yeah so now if I look might
be a little hard with that small the
lead in and lead out and try to smooth
this out I have my resolution down just
a little bit keep it smoother so let me
change one one option here and redraw
this if you look down here on the tool
path you can now see that we've got
you
zoom in a little more these two areas
here this is your lead in and lead out
now they're not quite as seen as normal
because they are smaller but we are
leading in and leading out so they can
be used to transition on and off of your
helix and a lot of times I will leave
them on that way I'm not once I get to
the bottom of my helix I'm not dragging
my tool up that finished wall but that
was that was a good question there okay
well that seems to be all the questions
in the chat section right now again
anyone who might have joined after we
got started we're keeping an eye on the
chat section for questions so whether
Jason's going to go on to the thread
mill block but if you have questions
regarding this helix you can certainly
add those and Wool we'll have another
Q&A session towards the end oh I guess
Jason without any other questions Carrie
all right we will jump into thread
milling now go ahead and switch programs
before I forget to do that and then
we'll come back to all that there so
thread milling for those of you that may
not be able or may not be familiar with
it it's just simply creating a thread
without using a tap you're going to put
a specific thread mill tool in and
you're going to use that to generate the
thread in your part now working when you
start with thread milling the first
thing that you're going to have to do is
is have a thread mill and you're going
to have to set that up in your tool
setup according to what you have and
when you go to set up a thread mill
you're going to notice it's going to ask
for two different types we have a thread
mill single cutter or a thread mill
multi cutter and these are two images of
what shows up in our tool setup advanced
tool settings when you choose these two
tools and I thought it may be helpful if
I give a more realistic image of what
they are so the one on the left is your
Mill fed middle single cutter and the
one on the right is your multi cutter
the single cutter you'll notice is just
going to have one or two inserts in it
and it can be used for many different
thread pitches you're going you'll
define that in your thread mill
datablock and that tool can be used to
cut multiple pitches we then head over
on the right side your thread mill Multi
cutter and this is a thread mill where
the thread pitch will be cut in either
an insert as you see in this larger
thread mill here or the pitch will be
ground right into the thread mill itself
but this this treadmill can only cut
this pitch of thread
so there's advantages and disadvantages
too to both the the single cut thread
mill or the single cutter thread mill
since it only has the one insert can be
used from a lot of different pitches
however when you're using that tool it
is gonna have to go the entire length of
the thread to cut that entire thread or
as the thread Multi cutter it's a little
bit limited because you do have to have
a separate cutter or separate insert for
each pitch that you intend to cut so
it's a little bit more limited in that
but it is going to cut faster because
you have more length of cut here and
we're going to talk about how the
control will utilize that a little bit
it's actually very important in your
tool setup page you'll notice that when
you choose thread mill multi cutter it's
going to ask you for length of cut right
on that main page you want to make sure
you set that up pretty accurately the
advantage with the multi cutter is once
one edge of that thread mill makes its
way out of the hole it can entrant
transition off of that thread and then
wrap it out so you don't have to chase
the entire length of that thread and
we'll we'll show you in our graphics
both ways here so in in my tool setup I
set up both so we can kind of see how
they differ I have a thread metal single
cutter just gave it a three
quarter inch diameter once we get into
the the print here you're gonna see that
we're cutting a rather large thread so
we have a little bit larger thread mill
and then we just set it up with speeds
and feeds like you would any other tool
I also set up a tool 101 which is my
thread mill multi cutter again roughly
the same size
cutters names be roughly the same speeds
and feeds the difference is that link
the cut here we're just gonna make a big
difference on how this thread is
actually cut when you go to cut it so
we'll we'll take a look at these again
in the data block and now let's take a
look at the part that we want to cut
we've got this large hex nut that we
need to cut here and again the red X
here represents the r0 so that's where
all our dimensions be coming from you
can see it's a rather large nut that's
three inches across these two flats and
we have a two-inch four-and-a-half
threaded hole in the centre of this
we've got a pretty coarse thread and
you'll see we have these thread minor
diameter here which will come into play
in just a second so if I take a look at
what we've created so far is I went
ahead
programmed the outside
this nut using the mill polygon and for
any of you that may not be familiar with
that make sure to let us know afterwards
and we can explain that a little bit and
then I just drilled a hole just kind of
in preparation of knowing I was going to
do an ID thread here if you look in my
tool data I used an inch and a half
drill just happen to be have a to be a
drill that I had set up so basically we
have the outside of the nut cut and a
hole that we still need to take the size
so if we look back at the print it says
that our thread minor diameter is one
point seven to seven so that's going to
be this inside diameter the smaller of
the the two diameters so I need to make
sure I go get that in in this part
before I go trying to shove a thread
mill down in the distance we are cutting
an ID thread so to do this I have a few
options I can use the mill circle I
could also use helix that that we just
went over so I think I'll do that just
to kind of reiterate the the helix so
I'll just go to my next block lines and
arcs helix and the ER I'm sorry lines
and arcs my X start will be the one
point seven two seven / - give me my X
start and why start will be zero and
we'll start a little bit above my my
part will use this tool number three
which three quarter inch in mill and I'm
just going to do a left cutter comp go
and program the helix again
counterclockwise we are going one inch
deep on this so I'm going to make sure I
go a little bit further will do will
just do in to make to make sure we have
plenty of room down there and do a
little bit bigger lead here and we'll do
a final helix just to make sure I clean
everything up again with this the second
helix making sure that your z end of the
second segment matches these the end of
your first segment is pretty critical
which will give you that nice flat
bottom and we'll do another 720 degrees
I should
and we go so now we've got
and taking the size
and now we can go in and and put a
thread in here so to do that I'm gonna
go to my next block it's still under
milling it's still a milling operation
you do have to hit more to get to your
more options here or your more softkeys
datablocks
and we're just simply going to choose
thread and this brings up the the mill
thread data block now for those of you
that may be new newer to the newer
versions of wind max you may notice that
we're starting to use this tabbed layout
this allows us to put more information
on the screen but keep it a little
easier for the operator to visually see
what's going on
so this first tab here we have the
thread tab and this is where we're going
to define the thread that we want to cut
so the radius of this thing I remember
it was a two inch something so I'm going
to put in a one inch radius and I need
to look back at that print
try to leave that up here so we have a
two inch
four and a half so the threads per inch
and wants to know how many threads we
have per inch which is four and a half
which gives us a pitch of 0.2 to two
which is you know a pretty coarse thread
we got a real kind of a big thread here
but basically we're just defining the
thread that we want to cut you know this
is a rather large thread and some of you
probably aren't used to seeing numbers
like this when dealing with threads just
to keep it simple let's say we were
going to do a 1/2 13th we'll switch this
back here in just a second but if we
were doing a 1/2 13 thread my radius the
quarter inch and then my threads branch
would be 13 threads per inch and then we
calculate the pitch for me so you just
give it the radius of your thread the
threads per inch which down at the
bottom up give you the tell you it is
looking for threads branch and it will
calculate the the pitch for you for
those of you that may work in metric
more than inch if I switch over to
metric let's say that I wanted to cut an
m12 by 1.75 it would be a if you're
doing an m12 the radius would be 6
millimeter and your pitch if you want
1.75 just type in 1.75 so you literally
just define the thread that you want to
cut in this thread section I'm going to
switch this back to inch and now make it
to match the print we're working on the
pretty coarse thread here so we we
define the thread over there in the left
section as far as the dimensions now
over here for the orientation this is
where it wants to know is this an ID or
an OD thread it's an inside or outside
we are cutting an inside thread so we're
going to leave that set to inside and
then we have a couple options down here
your start angle if you need to time
this thread with anything else on your
part for a nut that doesn't make a whole
lot of sense but if you had a part with
a thread
off of it and you need to make sure that
everything was timed so the thread
started ending at specific points you
could give it that angle that start
angle there so you can time your thread
if needed the taper angle down here this
gives you the ability to cut pipe taps
or tapered taps if needed if you are
going to cut pipe tabs or tapered taps
you're just going to give it the taper
angle here and I did a little bit of I
guess you could call research if you
want to call it that to see what that
angle should be and I've always used a
certain value and one made sure was
correct so I went to the Machinery's
handbook looked it up and it will tell
you the what the taper angle should be
for a pipe tap it gave it to me in
degrees minutes and seconds actually
this one here was just degrees and
minutes so I had to convert that to the
decimal equivalent so the the 47 or I'm
sorry one degree 47 minutes calculates
out to one point seven eight three
degrees we are looking for the decimal
equivalent here so for what it's worth
look that up that's the number we're
going to use I have seen it online with
slightly more
more information there a little bit more
precise but this is what we use here's
three we found it in the handbook go
back to our print for our program I'm
sorry so if I wanted to put that in it
was one point seven eight three but we
have the the option here you're making
this a positive or a negative angle I
happen to know that this is a negative
one point seven eight three for the for
the taper angle if you didn't know that
you do have a couple of options one and
and probably the most easiest is let's
exaggerate this number a little bit and
then let's draw it so let's say let's
make it a positive ten ten degrees to
start with and go ahead and get the draw
button
getting an error message I got to give
it a tool sorry about that so we put a
tool in there everything else you help
me we'll come back and talk about this
but I want to make sure it doesn't give
me any more issues here so I've kind of
exaggerated this a little bit it should
allow me to draw now
and if I look
my my side view here may be a little
hard to see on your screens but we're
actually cutting in the tapering out in
the wrong direction there was that being
a positive value he should be able to
see that we're kind of angling into the
park there a little bit so I were to go
in and make this a negative 10 degrees
you can see it's it's tapering inward
which is which is what we want that's
one option and typically might go to as
I can see very quickly on what it's
doing we also have the help menu here
and I'm going to look at that I did see
that it has a very useful picture here
that shows you if you're doing a
positive or negative angle so for what
it's worth it is there in the help menu
as well so I'm going to go ahead and put
this back at my minus one point seven
eight three and I will take this time to
mention that if you are going to use a
tapered thread that you have to use a
single cutter thread mill if I were to
switch this to that Multi cutter thread
mill you'll notice that that taper angle
goes away it assumes that if you have a
multi tooth or multi cutter Red Mill
that that angle will already be in your
your thread mill so if you do want to
use the tapered or cut a pipe tap you
have to use the single cut thread mill
and that'll bring it back so for now I'm
going to set this back to 0 since we're
not cutting a tapered thread and
everything should match for the thread
we're doing I'm now going to go into my
location tab we'll just simply give it
the center point we're now defining
where this thread is taking place and
then we'll come over to the right to the
to define where the thread starts and
stopped your XIV plunge start is very
similar to your Z start in every other
data block they're just kind of label
different to kind of force a little bit
of attention here
so this really has nothing to do with
your thread and we have your thread top
and thread bottom this is where you
define the length of your thread and
I'll usually cheat these a little bit so
if I know I want a full thread the top
and the bottom you know I'll take my top
up a little bit higher than my material
and I'll start my thread bottom a little
bit lower but this is where you're where
you put in the start and end of your
threads so if I were to cheat it a
little bit here
maybe we have a thread top a 55 of and a
thread bottom of one-inch if I were
going strictly off to the print you know
no cheating it at all I would just give
it a Z start of zero and a thread bottom
or I'm sorry a thread top of zero and a
thread bottom of -1 so just making sure
I get a full thread there and then we
have your direction of cut you'll notice
that we have four options in the soft
keys you can go counterclockwise up down
you know clockwise up and down so
basically have every option here to get
a right or left hand thread with going
up or or down I want a right hand thread
here and I'm gonna start at the bottom
of my thread and work my way up so I
know I'm going to be going up and to get
that right hand thread I'm gonna go
counterclockwise reason for going up is
I'm here a little bit later gonna switch
into that multi cutter thread and I want
to show you the advantages of doing that
and also I you know as I'm cutting these
chips I'm assuming that they're falling
down and gonna be out of my way so I'm
going to choose counterclockwise up and
we will be Clym cutting as another
benefit for going counterclockwise up as
well so we've got that set I go to the
process tab and we've got three
questions here the first one he enabled
cutter comp yes or no we've been giving
it all print dimensions here so yes we
want to enable cutter comp if you were
going through accounting
for the radiancy refuel and all these
you would just set that to no but
majority of time this will be set TS
your blend type this here is usually
kind of glanced over but it does warn a
little bit of conversation you'll notice
that we've got four options here two of
which are kind of like a 3d ramp where
you're gonna use X Y & Z and two of them
are just a 2d ramp we've got the used
blend helix and use blend ramps which
will both be a three axis type of
transition and then the blend arc and
blend lines will just be a 2d transition
now one thing you need to watch for is
we we told this in the location that we
wanted to go counterclockwise up meaning
I'm starting at the bottom of this hole
well since I'm starting at the bottom of
the hole if I choose helix which is
telling it to do that you know XYZ ramp
motion it actually has to shift my
thread up a little bit to be able to do
that helical transition so typically if
I'm starting at the bottom of the hole
I'll just do the standard arc or use
blend arcs in this and the soft keys if
you leave it set to helix I believe it's
about a quarter of your thread it'll
lift up so it'll do like one quadrant
move as it transitions into that thread
but it will lift it up which may affect
you getting a full thread so that I
don't have to worry about it I always
use the 2d options anyway so I'm just
gonna use a blend arc and since we are
doing a an ID thread it once know do we
want to start at the center of the whole
yes or no I don't have anything sticking
up in the center of this so I will leave
this set to two yes and transition that
way if I were to set it no they would
then look at your program parameters
your blend offset and overlap to
determine how to transition on and off
of this this thread so we went through
the three tabs we've completely defined
the thread and how we want it to cut now
we need to come down and deal with this
section here where you're going to give
it the tool
and then we got a another option down
here which is pretty nice as well
so I'm going to leave it at the the
single cutter for now and we'll switch
that a minute but if you look in the the
lower right hand corner we now have a
radial pet count where your Peck depth
is usually sitting so what this wants to
know is how many passes do you want to
take at this take when cutting this
thread and then your radial Peck depth
will be how much do you want each one of
those passes to take so if again if I
pull up my calculator we have a two inch
diameter and we have a one point seven
two seven Dianne error minor diameter so
if I subtract seven to seven and then
divide that by two so we're dealing with
each side here we're going to be taking
off about a hundred and thirty six
thousandths off of each side here so if
I wanted to take this let's say and four
passes and I wanted four equal passes I
can just do the point one three six five
divided by 4 and that will give me my
radio back up so this is basically
saying we're gonna take four passes at
it and each pass is going to be taken
off this much material so with that we
should have a thread again we are using
the single cutter thread mill we're
going to Isum
trickier kind of got a lot going on with
that with the thread mill and everything
or the helix but you should be able to
see we are now getting the thread mill
if we look at the top I told it I wanted
to take four different passes so you can
kind of see those four different passes
on the screen they're all starting at
the center point and transitioning out
to the outside I would like to note that
if you look at your solid rendering it's
not going to show you the exact threads
that takes a whole lot of processing
power to generate those threads and be
able to rotate everything around so
generally it's going to look like an end
mill just kind of ran through your part
but you are you are getting the geometry
you want if we do look at the bottom
here since this is such a coarse thread
you can kind of see some of it which
just happens to be the result of of the
dimensions we gave it but that is a
thread mill with a single cut and you
kind of see here by reset all that we do
have the thread coming all the way up to
the top if I were to go in and switch
this to that thread mill Multi cutter
which now has one inch length of cut
when I draw this it's going to look
slightly different and I can go in and
run it to make this a little bit more
clear but now you'll notice the start
and the end are way down in the bottom
of this hole the control has figured out
that with that one inch link the cut by
the time we get to this point over in
here the top of that insert or the top
of your thread mill it's already made it
outside of your thread so it can then
just transition back and off of the
thread so that's where the advantage
comes in with the multi cutter thread
mill you actually have to move less on
the machine to get it your your cutting
a larger majority of that thread at one
point so that is a that is thread mill
if anyone does have any questions we can
always come back in and and run this in
the auto mode if you'd like
any questions over that no we didn't get
any any questions typed in during that
session okay it's good we'll let it go
for a little bit here and see if there's
any more I know the other other day we
had kind of a we tried to get something
like this going before and had some
issues and someone had a question on the
pipe taps I hope what we did here was
enough to clear that up free of either
that may need to cut a tapered thread so
if any questions on that let us know
no nothing yet okay
hey Jason or is there anything else you
were going to cover or does that kind of
wrap us up for that well I think that
that's all I've got here if there's no
other questions so wait we do have one
okay
Jean is asking what about if the fit
means to be adjusted okay so if it's all
good to help not just that you can do it
just like any other data block you can
either adjust your radius in the thread
data block or you can go into your tool
set up and the Geoff's either your
diameter or the diameter where so as far
as adjusting it's going to work just
like any other data block that we have
on the control
okay and the last question here is on a
taper and thread will a start or end at
the major diameter
I believe depending on which way you
program it for angle let's go take a
look here
actually let me get back in a thread no
data block it should start at whatever
the number of packs and distance away
correct yes
yeah it'll still do that and maybe I was
misunderstanding the question there it
what Mike just said did that answer the
the question yeah I believe I understand
it correctly if you tell it to starter
for pack counts at let's say 50,000 each
then it wouldn't started away at two
hundred thousandth from your final
diameter so that's how we could control
it yeah yeah that's correct for the
question yeah well we'll assume that did
it if not we can he says he meant the
start of the angle okay so that is what
I I was thinking and I thought when I
looked in here the other day I looked
see what it had to say four threads
they're tapered threads and I thought it
gave mention to that so let me see if it
does
it is not so it would easy major because
as you mean we put in the angle the
negative angle we're tapering in so
we're giving at that top dimension but I
thought you know what I I think I know
where I may have I may be getting
something confused with the Machinery's
handbook that I read here so it would be
the top it's all based on your your
angle if that makes sense cuz we told it
to start at a given radius and then
taper in at a negative 1.7 whatever that
number was so okay it's like a major is
that that makes sense yeah hopefully
that answered the question we have two
more questions one could you use this to
in a to milli tapered hole yes that is a
very good question and I had considered
I know this is one that might could
actually suggested a long long time ago
using this for I've never done it but I
have heard of people doing it if you
were to go in and program so you did
have a tapered thread that you want to
cut and you want to get the taper close
before hand you could just go in give it
a radius and when it comes to your
thread thread spur insert or your pitch
just give that something very small so
you would essentially be surfacing that
taper so yes that is something you could
do and we use a bottle-nosed end mill
for that yeah and then last one here is
they're asking if you could go over the
polygon block yeah we have one right
here
so the polygon is it's a really nice
feature for let me get back to our print
here it's a really nice feature for just
quickly getting this geometry in so you
can see here we have a hex so we're
going to tell the number of sides in our
polygon which it defaults to six and
that's the most commonly cut you're
going to give it the center point of
your
your polygon and then we have this
sizing method basically it's going to
give you three options for how do you
want to size your polygon we've got the
outer diameter the inner diameter or
side length so if you were given a
dimension like we have here where we're
going across the flats you're going to
give it the inner diameter because
basically if you picture a circle going
through here that would be the inner
diameter which is what I gave it here
inner diameter gave it my three inch
diameter if you were given a dimension
that was going across the the points on
this polygon you would then give it the
outer diameter and give it that
dimension or if your parent just
happened to have a dimension of a single
side length you could choose side length
and give it that two size the rest of
your your polygon and you just give it
the size and your orientation angle if
you leave it at zero one of your flats
it's always going to be down towards the
bottom then you have your Z starts the
bottom like any other data block and
then this corner radius feature gives
the ability to round each one of these
corners slightly which which I really
like in the past that would program this
feature by milling a contour or I'm
sorry yet programming one line and then
using pad and rotate to get the rest but
you didn't get quite as smooth a cutting
motion and you didn't have the option of
easily rounding the corner so this is a
nice way of doing it and you can set
this for you know whatever however many
sides you want if I go in and put it at
four sides now I'm going to get
something all different when I hit draw
so you just simply tell it the number of
sides and the size of it
so hopefully that clears up the the
polygon data block for those of you they
haven't seen it once you get into it you
know if you just kind of look at the
questions and the the what it's asking
down below it will it make makes a lot
of sense and a very easy way to program
these this type of geometry okay well um
Jason if you don't have any more I don't
have any more questions that are popping
up here so I guess we can go ahead and
wrap this up for today
we have been recording this and we will
send everyone a copy of the recording as
well as we'll be sending out a message
for what the next webinar topic will be
so hopefully everyone can join us again
which I believe that is what Friday
Jason yeah be Friday at 1 o'clock when
will we'll have some more for you we
plan on doing one hopefully every Friday
for for a while to get some some more
interaction with the control and sorry
as I I was working there I was pulling
this information up I some of you may
still have questions that didn't get
covered here maybe a little bit more
specific or maybe you were one that
wanted the the desktop software this
here's our applications number you see
my information there and my desk phone
in my email feel free to email me there
or we have the herckel applications
Department which is always available
there's always someone monitoring that
where you can call with any questions
call or email with any questions but if
you if you want the desktop software
make sure to jot this down and let us
know now or any questions over what we
covered today all right very good well
thanks everybody for taking the time to
watch this and I guess we will see you
on Friday all right thank you